[Applause]
please please mr. Crowder if you'd like
to make your opening
thank you let's hear it for you -
Republicans putting this on come on let
him know you love him
let's hear it for my little ant even
though you love him
let's hear for Miss summers let her know
you love her time to listen up you silly
liberal fruitcakes I came out I wanted
to tell some jokes let's do some reality
checks here you have any idea sir how
pathetic it must be to be you these
people wanted to come out and have a
good time here a few jokes and
thoughtful discussion but your head pops
off the pillow in the morning with oh
how could I be a professional victim
today let me go in and screw with their
act just because oh my god your parents
didn't tell you that your opinion wasn't
worth that much look look they're
confused they're confused you know why
because I'm not your gender studies
professional a cater to your trigger
warning microaggressions safeSpace
[ __ ] I don't want to do this I want
to come out and tell a few jokes you
created this monster we have to go ten
more minutes of this let this
reverberate let it be a life lesson this
monster right here that you're so afraid
of the face you see in your nightmares
was created by social justice warrior
[ __ ] like you
and now you have and now you have this
wonderful [ __ ] that's what happens be
okay we're good yeah yeah darling you
can call me what you like okay there we
go
crying out loud listen nobody here wants
to hear your opinion that much and
here's what's so crazy you couldn't wait
5 minutes
unlike leftist we have an open panel in
a Q&A session because we want an open
idea Oh on the races there you go listen
new one where'd you learn that one in
social human studies 101 right next to
the right next to the giant I don't know
wild boar I couldn't see you said
there's no such thing as bad chips ah
guess what if you think there aren't you
are one okay yeah I didn't know it's
okay because I got some here so screw
you I have a [ __ ] pass and a fat pass
today we wanted to come out here and
tell a few jokes we wouldn't have a
thoughtful discussion we want an open
conversation of ideas you guys can't be
grown adults enough to literally wait 10
minutes to the point where we open the
floor and I'm like leftist guess what we
don't try and ban you when your speakers
come to school we don't show up in
protest and call them oh shut up you
just got owned and they are trying to
come back five minutes later it's like
George
the jerk stork oh they're running out of
you George Costanza you androgynous
little amoeba and by the way these
opinions are yelling out they're not
even your opinions they're your opinions
from your gender studies professor the
really reason you picked it was because
you thought it was your best chance at
getting laid you just decided to walk on
in to try and pick up chicks at the San
Francisco retread pot-smoking drum
circle only to realize that you're very
glance in the direction of a woman
causes a barren room how do you think
it's gonna get better
No no privilege that's not going to
happen I don't want to come out here and
give someone the finger but it's because
he walked out of this chick is it start
a show like that this is absurd at least
when you go back to like Christina
Christina
sorry christina hoff sommers days
self-professed democrats hippies the
retreads that you guys want to be least
they thought that we're fighting the
system they thought they were trying to
create transparency they really thought
they were for free speech you people are
openly and completely against it you're
not fighting for free speech you're not
fighting for rights you're fighting for
the right to be a [ __ ] and not your
opinions that you don't like
I'm done oh if you only take if you only
take one piece of advice from this okay
please sincerely don't be an [ __ ]
your whole life all right